okay here's the rats and this is from
rock banks eps work rat he was the first
guy who figured out the rats giggle and
you might think well what kind of stupid
thing is that to study is like $50,000
research grant for giggling rats you
know aside but he discovered the play
circuitry in mammals that's a big deal
right it's like discovering a whole new
continent there's a play circuit in
mammals it's built right in so it's not
socially constructed there's a there's a
biological platform for that and so what
what pen step would do with rats he
found out if rats if you take a rat puff
away from its mother it dies even if you
feed it even if you keep it warm it dies
now you can stop it from dying by taking
a pencil with an eraser on the end and
massaging it right because rats won't
live without love and the same thing
happens to human babies and we saw that
Romania when there was that catastrophe
have to tell Tesco in the orphanages
where the orphanages were full of
unwanted babies because Ceausescu
insisted that every Romanian woman was
constantly pregnant so the orphanage
just stacked up with unwanted babies and
lots of them didn't even have names and
they were warehoused warm shelter food
devastating lots of them died most of
them died before the first year and the
ones that did he died were permanently
dysfunctional because you have to be
touched if you're a human being it's not
an option you have to be played with
it's not an option it's it's part of
neural developmental necessity and and
you have to also play fair so because
otherwise you produce a very disjointed
child who isn't able to engage in the
niceties of social interaction which is
continual play in some sense and
reciprocity so what panksepp did with
his rat he noticed that male rats
juveniles really liked to wrestle and
they wrestle just like humans beings
wrestle they pinned each other for
crying out loud looked like that that
rat had just lost he's down for a ten
count right and so so what you do is you
take juvenile rats and you can find out
that they want to play because you can
attach a spring to them and then they'll
try to run and you can measure how hard
they're running by how hard they're
pulling on the spring and then you can
estimate how motivated they are and so
you can find out that a nice well said
that whoo
doesn't have anything on his mind will
still work hard to play it to enter an
arena where he's been allowed to play
before he'll work for that so that you
think while the rats motivated so the
two rats go out there and they play and
and so they're playing like dogs play
and everyone knows what that looks like
if you're you know what if you have any
sense about dogs they kind of go like
this and kids do that and maybe you do
that with your wife if you're gonna play
with her a little bit okay
my poor my poor wife man when she huh
she was a she was a young she had older
siblings and so she wasn't played with
as much when she was little as she might
have been and I used to like you know
what you take a pillow away and you go
like this three times right that means
look out a pillow is coming your way so
I go one two three
Wow but she looked she was completely
dismayed at me like what do you do that
for and I thought well I eventually
taught her that rule the other thing I
used to do
[Applause]
the other thing I used to do you know
and so sometimes she'd come at me like
this when we were playing round and I
grabbed her wrist and I'd knock her for
her her hamster her knuckles together
and she used to just get completely
annoyed about that and I thought right
that's what you do you just opened your
hands well she didn't know that either
so she hadn't been played with enough
when she was a little rat and so anyways
uh anyway so you let the rap the little
rats go out there right and so let's
imagine one of them is ten percent
bigger than other and so that the ten
percent bigger rat wins because ten
percent is enough in rat way to ensure
that you're going to be the Pinner
rather than the penny okay so so that's
fine so in it Annette the rat throughout
pins the big rat pins a little rat and
now the big rat is the is the authority
rat and so then the next time that the
rats play the little rat has to invite
the big rat to play so the big rats out
there being cool and the little rat pops
up and you know does the whole will you
play with me thing and the big rat will
deign to play with them but if you pair
them repeatedly unless the big rat lets
the little rat wins thirty percent of
the time the little rat will not invite
him to play and panksepp discovered that
it's like I read that that just blew me
away it's like that is so amazing
because you see well first of they're
there's an analogy to psays ideas about
the emergence of morality out of play
and human being so that was very cool
but the notion that that was built into
rats at the level of wrestling with and
their social they're deeply social
animals right they have to know how to
get along with one another and most of
their authority disputes Dorman's
disputes you don't want them to end in
bloodshed and combat because you know if
your rat won and I'm rat to and we tear
each other just thrash Reds in a
dominance dispute rat three is just
going to move in it's really not a great
strategy and so be better if we could
settle our differences you know somewhat
peacefully and so while so rat
anyways pegs have figured out that rats
plan not only that they play they play
fair and they seem to enjoy it he also
figured out this was really cool too
that if you give juvenile rats attention
deficit disorder drugs ritalin
suppresses prey play so that's worth
thinking about it's like well why do you
have to give juvenile human beings and
set amines in school well because they
need to play well you know they don't
get to play you know get to wrestle
around I mean that's oppression as far
as I can tell they don't get to wrestle
around that's fine feed them some
amphetamines man that'll shut down the
old play circuits well here's the other
problem is tanks have found out that if
you don't let juvenile male rats play
their prefrontal cortexes don't develop
properly
surprise surprise you're not letting the
mature it's like what else would you
expect so you know that's something to
think about really hard I would say